oh my god it's true this is so exciting
oh hi I'm Megan and recently I completed
six items off my bucket list in six days
and now I just want to give someone else
the opportunity to live their best lives
the point isn't to complete your bucket
list it's just to get a running start
this week we're gonna go on an adventure
with Brian Graham he's a video producer
here at BuzzFeed and the most joyful
smile eosin you will ever meet
come on in Ryan that was really nice I
didn't know what you're gonna say can
you put your penis not all of them so if
you were to cross off three things from
your bucket list what would they be
first I would love to go drag racing I'm
a bit of a control freak so it'll be
really hard for me to be in a passenger
seat going 100 miles an hour and just
trusting and letting go the second thing
I wanted to do is stay in an actual
haunted house but I think there's
something about being in something that
has actually experienced like tragedy or
something scary no could you imagine
being taken over by a goat I prefer not
to my third thing not to be confused
with drag racing is to dress and perform
in drag that's probably my ultimate
bucket list I'm honestly I mean if
you're not busy this week I think we can
make that happen
really drag racing tomorrow Oh tomorrow
but you have to finish all these furs oh
yeah they were very expensive all right
more fries
[Music]
[Applause]
what a beautiful data steer the [ __ ]
outa Ryan today we're at exotic racing
in Fontana well Ryan will be in the
passenger seat of the vehicle going over
125 miles per hour but what he doesn't
know is when he's gonna be taking off so
I've told the driver to basically
pretend like he's gonna take some time
to show them the buttons and make sure
you what these things do in the boom
he's gonna take off scare the [ __ ] outta
Ryan cuz that's what this is all about
right right why is this on your bucket
list and why must do you do this before
you die I'm a little bit of a control
freak after today I'm hoping that this
feeling of letting go and trusting
bleeds into other areas of my life I
don't know it'll be fun or I'll die
either way what's the worst again you're
making me nervous
stop it all right let's go do people
crash you know if I told you no I'd be
lying
you ready as ready as I'll what we have
up here in front of us is a won't go to
mile road course I'll gonna be
straightaway
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow this is like the coolest thing I
think I've ever done in my life like it
was such a free experience I had to just
be in the car and let it happen but
that's how day one was I can only
imagine how day two and day three you're
gonna be thank you so much so Ryan is
really jazzed to stay somewhere haunted
tonight but what he doesn't know is that
I've booked us the most notoriously
haunted room in the most notoriously
haunted boat in America the Queen Mary
are we ready to go yet yep all right
take a step up up yep there you go
do you remember saying that being afraid
made you feel alive that's what you're
looking for
yes yeah okay just remember that holy
crap we may be why is this on your
bucket list why do you want to be
haunted so bad something about being
around ghosts and being scared that fear
is like so thrilling that it's it makes
you feel alive hardly helps you get
possessed something I can you like that
way I can interact let's just go take
the tour my name is Commodore Everett
hoard this ship carried 2.5 million
passengers back and forth across the
Atlantic in war and peace a lot of those
guys that went over in the ship did not
come home some of their last memories
were scratched into the handrails all
the way around the top of the ship
I like that ship has a wonderful happy
presence about it and a lot of people do
have experiences I hear people talk I
heard one speak in 2011 windows Eddie is
she said I'm so cold
I'm so very clear oblique we're gonna go
to cabin B 3
that's where we're sleeping tonight oh
good if there's anything that will
happen it would be be 3/4 we're going
further and further beneath the sea now
oh I do that on purpose
oh I don't know but I was getting the
strobing effect on my camera too but now
was that doing upstairs
[Music]
so you wouldn't stay in this room is
what you're telling me no when I would
go in there there were so many reports
of incidents happening in the cabin that
they finally stopped drinking enough to
people people had reported lights
turning on and off water starting a lot
or stopping the thing is that neither of
us tried to protect these oh you're
gonna go in there right now yeah I'm
needed on the bridge I don't like this
oh okay okay
it's just a little creepy oh no oh that
can't be a thing that freaked me out
is this okay like I feel like I can stay
here it don't smell like new it smell
like death what are those doors no see
now if something pops out at me I swear
to God I was gonna be there
what no that was a real noise yeah hold
on cuz they like it came flowing over
here you really hear that like knocking
Megan stop playing hey no wait wait wait
maybe I swear I heard an eye look if you
fall asleep and waking you up okay this
is home this is gonna be home I hate you
all right crew so it's just gonna be me
and Megan and your ghost and the ghosts
and all the ghosts like review the
footage immediately but don't tell us
what you saw oh my god no tell me
[Music]
can we do have to sit on the floor yeah
what you can't do this in the bed the
floor feels dangerous come on for a
mental health we're keeping a light on
let's do this good night
[Music]
it's funny because like we thought we
were gonna find ghosts we ended up
becoming the ghosts instead I slept
surprisingly well it was cool to get to
be here and have those moments of fear
and just like get over and concrete I'm
really glad you're gonna check this off
your bucket list and I'm really glad
that I never have to come here so today
Ryan is being transformed into a drag
queen but what I haven't told him is
that he's gonna perform for all of our
co-workers tomorrow
but will tell him that later all right
Ryan I brought in the one and only most
wonderful LA Queen
Anita procedure why is transforming into
a drag queen on your bucket list because
I feel like there's so much confidence
you have to have when you're performing
dragon being a drag queen and I feel
like that is some of that in my everyday
life I don't know if I necessarily have
I was closeted for so long in my life
that it's a part of me that I feel like
I want to explore and push more today
it's part of your drag training we are
gonna be going over walking in heels
tucking 101 and we'll be getting you
ready for your performance tomorrow
night performance I'll do it it's gonna
be great it's a little kick ball change
a little one to step in front of your
co-workers okay okay all right let's get
to it
let's get rehearsing Hey look what we
have Oh still made from Milan oh I've
never liked watch walking heels like a
put heels on before in my lifetime let's
go for it let's do a little strut don't
look down don't look down don't
second-guess it
[Music]
don't take out the equipment girl give
it to them give it to them yes [ __ ]
keep going I did not tell you to stop
okay so now oh that you are armed with
all the knowledge you need to pound a
runway we got to get you an outfit girl
so let's take a look at our beautiful
rack of clothing that are definitely not
from Goodwill and see what we can find
you
[Music]
bring it in
okay hit me move that bus is this it
oh babe that one is ad this is gonna be
the perfect outfit for drag queen Ryan
you got your essence yes it does the
only thing I'm worried about is that
there's just a whole lotta little too
much assets yeah we are gonna teach you
about tucking girl come with me come on
[Music]
basically you want to get your balls in
your ass slap and then your dick between
your hands you get in there you put that
down and then now your lady she's tags
and ready yeah feel like a lady okay so
here we are we are in the dance studio
it's time to go over your routine for
tomorrow yeah let's play it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's 5:00 p.m. so we're gonna take a
break be back tomorrow for your
performance let's go home so I'm here
I'm ready to get this face beat so we've
kinda been putting together your look
but how do you feel about your drag
persona like what kind of girl is she I
wanted to be someone who's very
confident and very like I mean I want to
say like [ __ ] but just like hmm like
just very I guess fierce good are you a
good [ __ ] or a bad [ __ ]
somewhere between
[Music]
[Music]
okay eyes are officially closed okay
okay they're closed I'm like shaky all
right oh yeah Wow yes well I do look
wealthy I'm not gonna look [ __ ] good
I know it's me
but like this is like another side of me
this is some more this is some more
dollars I mean yes some more dollars it
came to me in a dream last night okay
she's quite wealthy if you didn't know
she bought this fur just to throw it
away I am ready to go perform for my
coworkers mm-hmm I'm gonna go serve the
children feet and bless them really
[Music]
hello hello hello BuzzFeed how y'all
doing
[Applause]
I've had the privilege of transforming
Ryan into a [ __ ] drag queen yah
it has been so much fun so this is one
of the things on his bucket list I am so
excited to announce the worldwide
premiere of his new persona some more
Dollaz
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this was one of the coolest things I've
ever done in my life I feel like I can
do it I'm on top of it I feel like I can
go on and live my best sell from here on
out I'm so happy thank you so much yeah
all right well go do it go live your
best life okay wait wait come back
there's a million other people who
haven't even started their bucket list
no need to go find them leave more work
to new people
[Music]